Good evening, everybody.
I trust you had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, though I hope it has been happy.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambho Tassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambho Tassa
Namo tassa bhagavato arhato samma sambuddhassa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So we were looking at the discourse where Bhakta Gauta has come to see the Buddha.
And just to remind you of these ten questions,
undetermined questions or undetermined questions, known as abhyakta.
The Buddha wouldn't answer them because when it came to himself, of course, there was always a presumption of a self.
of somebody who exists or not exists etc but here we can see some of the obsessions of the age about the world being eternal or not eternal whether it was finite or infinite space and time
whether the body and the soul are one.
So that's obviously a materialist position, the body and soul are one, body and mind.
Soul here, I think, is a word that might combine for us our emotional life and thinking life, because the English word mind tends to be stuck up here.
And, of course, this quadrilemma,
between does the Buddha exist or not exist, then some sort of synthesis that he exists and not exists, and then this impossibility of neither exists nor not exists.
So I'll just clear my throat.
Thank you.
Yeah, nobody's going to get me a drink of water.
I don't know why I should be a dry throaty.
So anyway, the Buddha won't answer any of this stuff.
And he then, he gives his opinion of speculative views.
A thicket of views, a wilderness of views, a contortion of views, a vacillation of views, going from this to that, doubt, a fetter of views.
And it's beset by suffering, by vexation, by despair and by fever.
Because to these things, you know, there can't be any objective.
Oh, thank you.
There can't be any objective proof.
You know, it's the same with God or anything which is beyond physicality.
How are you going to prove it?
It doesn't lead to disenchantment, dispassion, cessation and to peace, to direct knowledge, to enlightenment or nibbana.
Now a question came through about disinterest and disenchantment.
so a disinterest um means you know you're not interested in something anymore and boredom often masquerades as disinterest but the difference is that when you're bored with something you know give it a couple of hours a couple of days a couple of weeks and you want it again but this interest really you've lost interest in it it no longer interests you
And that can be because you become disenchanted or you've just grown out of it, as children do from, you know, snakes and ladders and tiddlywinks.
And they grow into something more sophisticated, graphs or something.
But this disenchantment is to suddenly see through the delusion that we're suffering from.
And it's always to do with this identity.
What do we identify with?
That's the question.
And if we identify with anything, then, of course, we have a great right.
So this is as far as we got.
Speculative views.
So now he's got another set of questions.
When someone's mind is liberated thus, where does he reappear after death, you see?
So when somebody is fully liberated, fully awakened, where does he reappear?
So again, you see, the term reappears does not apply, Vajra.
Well, where does he not reappear?
He says, the term not reappear does not apply, Vajra.
Well, does he both reappear and not reappear?
He says, no, no, no, that just won't do, you see, does not apply.
What about neither reappears nor does not reappear?
And he says, no, neither reappears nor does not reappear, does not apply, Thatcher.
Now, when Master Gautama is asked these four questions, he replies the term reappears does not apply, Thatcher.
The term does not reappear does not apply.
The term both reappears and does not reappear does not apply.
and neither reappears nor does not reappear, does not apply, Vajra.
Here I have fallen into bewilderment, Master Gautama.
Here I have fallen into confusion.
And the measure of confidence I had gained through previous conversation with Master Gautama has now disappeared."
So he's completely confused by these negative responses.
And the reason, of course, why the Buddha replies like this is that Vajragocha is always somewhere in the question, presuming somebody has reappeared or not reappeared.
So the Buddha says, well, it's enough to cause you bewilderment, Vajra.
It's enough to cause you confusion.
For this Dhamma, Vacha, is profound, hard to see and hard to understand, peaceful and sublime, unattainable by mere reasoning, subtle to be experienced by the wise.
It's hard for you to understand it when you hold another view, accept another teaching, approve of another teaching, pursue a different training and follow a different teacher.
So I shall question you about this in return, Vacha.
Answer as you choose.
What do you think, Vacha?
Suppose a fire were burning before you, would you know this fire is burning in front of me?
I would, Master Gautama.
And if someone were to ask you, Vacha, what does this fire burning in front of you depend on?
Being asked thus, Master Gautama, I would ask that this fire burning in front of me burns in dependence on grass and sticks.
If that fire before you were to be extinguished, would you know this fire before me has been extinguished?
I would, Master Gautama.
And if someone were to ask you, Pacha, when that fire before you was extinguished, which direction did it go?
To the east, to the west, to the north or the south?
Being asked thus, what would your answer be?
That does not apply, Master Gautama, the fire burned in dependence on its fuel of grass and sticks.
And when this was used up, if it does not get any more fuel, being without fuel, it is reckoned as extinguished.
So too, Vāca, the Tathāgata has abandoned that material form by which one describing the Tathāgata might describe him.
so how do we describe somebody who's gone beyond any form of description so here you've got the buddha's difficulty in trying to express something which is by definition inexpressible it's ineffable it's beyond language and he goes on he says well i've cut it off at the root i've made it made it like a palm stump
uh done away with it so that it no longer subject to future arising the tataka is liberated from reckoning you can't you can't in terms of material form he's profound immeasurable hard to fathom like the ocean and that's why these terms don't apply
So whatever is within us, which finally liberates itself from this delusion of being this psychophysical organism, is something that simply cannot be described by any words or by any images.
That's what the Buddha is telling him, you see.
And then he goes through the five khandhas.
So the first is form, the body, and then there's feelings.
So he says the same about feelings, the same about perception and concepts and images and all that, the same about all the habits that constitute a human being, all these habits that are caused by or are maintained by our volition.
And finally, of course, the screen of consciousness upon which it all arises.
So now we have to go to the physics of the time.
When Westerners first came across this, the theologians and philosophers, they just presumed it was some form of subtle extinction.
So the Buddha was simply a clever materialist.
In the end, everything disappeared and that was the end of it.
And one of the examples to show that was this image of the fire being extinguished.
But the physics of the time was that the four elements, so the earth element, which is to do with extension, solidity, etc.
The fire element, which is to do with any form of heat or cold.
The water element, which is to with cohesiveness.
So you can see the feel of that in water or an elastic band or something.
And finally, of course,
air or wind sometimes it's it's defined as wind which is movement now it is said that all these four elements are everywhere at all times in some uh in some combination or another so when this fire
so when it was understood that when you rub two sticks together it wasn't the friction between the two sticks that was causing the heat and therefore the fire it was it was by rubbing two sticks you were calling you were calling the fire element around everywhere to come
and be there in those sticks and grass.
And that's why it was often used as an expression of attachment.
So now when the fire is extinguished, the fire element simply goes into a non-grasping state.
See, that's the point.
So there's not a destruction of the fire element.
There's only a destruction of this fire.
And as I say, it's often used as an example of clinging.
So what the Buddha is saying that there's something in us, which once it's lost its identity with this psychophysical organism, all this thing about, I think, I feel, I am the body, etc.
When all that's gone,
there is a release of that which knows.
And that, of course, is your satipanya, your intuitive awareness.
Now, when you're meditating and you've accessed that observation post within yourself and you are observing sensations coming from the body or hearing things at the ear or you're feeling things in the body or you can see, you know, images and thoughts in your mind, remember that
unwittingly, you might say, we have pulled out of the identity with all these things.
We're actually identifying with this observer, identifying with the feeler, the one who knows.
So, you know, it's like in your meditation, try to make that sort of obvious to yourself, you know, by saying, well, who is the observer?
Who is the feeler?
But it is because it's not what is actually being felt and observed.
And so at that point within ourselves, when we are the observer, we've only got to, as it were, jump that one more step to go beyond the idea of some body observing, some body feeling.
And that will happen naturally with time, with the effort, with that question mark constantly in the mind.
so that's the buddha's answer uh and he warns us that uh trying to trying to describe this is is is a fool's game which i've just done of course so so we've now come to the end of the discourse and and this is a vachagota seems to um seems to have clicked master gotama supposing there were a great sala tree not far from the village or town
and impermanence wore away its branches and foliage, its bark and its sapwood, so that on a later occasion, being divested of branches and foliage, divested of bark and sapwood, it became pure, consisting entirely of heartwood.
So too this discourse of Master Gautama is divested of branches and foliage, divested of bark and sapwood, and is pure, consisting entirely of heartwood.
So in other words, he's got right down to the root of the whole problem.
Now this is really convinced Vachagota because he says, magnificent Master Gautama, magnificent Master Gautama.
Master Gautama has made the Dhamma clear in many ways as though he were turning upright what had been overthrown, revealing what was hidden, showing the way to one who was lost or holding up a lamp in the dark for those with eyesight to see form.
I go to Master Gautama for refuge, to the Dharma and to the Sangha.
From today, let Master Gautama remember me as a lay follower who has gone to him for refuge, for life.
So he was obviously...
He was obviously well affected by the Buddha's image or metaphor of the fire.
He finally got it.
So we'll see.
We'll see tomorrow because there is a greater discourse on Vajragota, which we'll have a look at tomorrow.
And I think this is probably happened before, but we'll see anyway.
So I hope that the questions that Vajra got has also enlivened you and made things clear as it has done for him.
And that you will, by your continuing practice, break through this delusion of self and attain pure enlightenment, pure liberation from suffering sooner rather than later.
So we can begin our meditation.